welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for marvel studios werewolf by
night an mcu halloween special coming
october 7th unveiled at d23 now we're
still wondering how this will connect to
the mcu but i don't know after sightings
of man thing in the tva in this trailer
who knows this is feige's sandbox and
what if an iron groot kind of connects
so surely this will too so let's break
down this footage frame by frame to
explain what this spooky thing is and
all the easter eggs that you missed
let's get started
[Music]
okay we gotta start here because this is
a brand new mcu intro a marvel studios
special presentation at the d23 panel
that i attended kevin feige said that
this specials director composer michael
giacchino actually cut together this
trailer in its music and jaquino is
actually the guy who can post marvel
studios fanfare that we have heard on
every mcu title since 2016.
but his music hears some upbeat bongos
which when mixed with the neon colors in
the text font is a clear riff on the
intros that you would see before tv
specials in the 80s and 90s this intro
ends though with a beastly roar over
squishy sound
ooh we must investigate that sound i'll
be right back this halloween
you can't escape the shock
the terror
werewolf by night i love it i can't
believe i'm breaking in a trailer like
this because i was a kid without a ton
of friends who grew up spending my
halloweens alone watching tv specials
just like this it's like i was made for
this so werewolf by night is jack
russell aka jacob rusoff a lycanthrope
with a blood curse from his lineage
originally an ancestor in the 18th
century tried to kill dracula but got
bitten by a dracula's werewolf jacob's
father gregor reawakened this blood
curse in the 20th century by reading a
spell from the darkhold hole werewolf by
night was a marvel spotlight horror
character in the 1970s and actually
werewolf by night number 32 was the
first comic appearance of moon knight
and moon night episode 2 actually
included an easter egg referencing this
the bus was numbered
wbn032 werewolf by knight number 32 so
shaquino is telling a werewolf by night
story in the style of horror chillers
from the 30s and 40s which is really the
heyday of universal's horror classics
like frankenstein the invisible man and
the wolf man but the wide shot of this
location is interesting it's kind of
like an isolated pueblo with some adobe
designs this might connect with jack
russell in the mcu being played by
mexican actor guy garcia bernal i love
this actor if you haven't seen station
11 yet watch it but if you look on the
outskirts of this town it just looks
like enclosed and surrounded by
nothingness a kind of void its
architecture looks like a surreal m.c
escher labyrinth it's really perfect for
a haunted maze or a laser tag arena from
which there is no exit but what exactly
is this setting in the context of the
mcu i do a few theories we'll get to
them later but for now just note that
there is a shadow moving against the
wall in the upper right section of this
town there is a monster on the loose in
this town you like monsters right of
course you do you have a pulse and
that's why you should get monster
legends a free to play mobile game where
you can collect over 1 000 monsters and
build your own monster empire breed your
monsters to create a new species
feed them to make them strong
and then go to war against other players
to win rewards and now monster legends
has something special for fans of the
walking dead six new monsters inspired
by rick
daryl
carol
michonne negan and maggie if you could
score daryl maggie rick and carol as
they become available in the game you'll
receive the negan monster for free not
enough twd for you master the dungeon
and get the indestructible michonne
monster start playing now for a limited
time and you'll get a special free
starter pack with 100 000 gold 20 000
food three gems in mothman all you got
to do is download the monster legends
now using the link in the description or
the qr code laura donnelly plays elsa
bloodstone a marvel buffy style monster
hunter introduced in 2001 and often
shows up in horror titles at one point a
member of the midnight suns alongside
blade man thing and ghost rider the
bearded hunter is named joven played by
actor kirk thatcher who is an ilm
creature designer known for cameos
movies like star trek 4 the voyage home
and he plays pretty much the same
character in spider-man homecoming in
the mcu making this his second mcu role
so is this the same guy well if you
think back on homecoming the guy
standing next to him in that scene was
zack cherry's do a flip guy and he
played essentially the same person in
shanghai it would be awesome if joven
was that boombox guy in homecoming and
he moonlights literally as a monster
hunter or maybe this guy is a variant of
the boombox guy on to the next clip
tonight
it is every hunter for
themselves good luck
i'll be
rotting for you
so we meet verusa played by harriet
sansom harris the various hunters in the
room are all wearing the same badge
including barusa as if they're all part
of a league of monster hunters but it
sounds like verusa has called all these
hunters together because one of them has
secretly been bitten by a werewolf and
she wants to out them this is pretty
much a narrative version of the game
werewolf get andrew garfield on the
guest list i'm not the werewolf this
animatronic zombie is named ulysses
maybe based on ulysses bloodstone elsa's
monster hunting father this animatron's
appearance and spooky pun feels like
going onto the humor of the crypt keeper
and tales from the crypt giaquino said
this is gonna be a scary title but it's
also gonna have some humor and the way
the movie poltergeist is kind of a mix
of warm-hearted humor and terrifying
chills but uh but at the end of the day
poltergeist probably one of the scariest
movies of all time let's move on
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
i can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
[Applause]
rusa connects this ritual with a skull
wow there's this man with the sash often
seen behind her this is actor al
haymaker he's playing a character named
billy swann i'm assuming this is a
ritual to draw out the werewolf amongst
them but once jack is revealed as a
werewolf it looks like he attacks
escapes from that cage and forces the
others to hunt him down throughout the
town onto the next clip
[Music]
so through this cage jack is prodded by
these armed soldiers that i'm pretty
sure are tva hunters from loki so this
town could be contained within the void
of the tva maybe monster hunters from
another reality are kept in this black
and white pocket reality that's overseen
by the tva because mobius did mention
that they have a nightmare department
another scene he says the tva has dealt
with things like vampires before you
know we brought in cree
titans vampires why is it the two orphan
demigods are such a pain in the ass and
yet it was your idea to bring in another
one the black and whiteness of this
could be a feature of this pocket
dimension as it is for the shadow realm
and thor love and thunder now tva time
sticks would not shock him like that
they'd just prune him right but maybe
they're trying to prune him like extract
this werewolf from this reality but it
is not working there is one shot of the
tva providing him in the back and it's
our clearest look of jack's werewolf
form clearly they are leaning into the
practical costume and makeup approach
compared to like the effects which also
just really plays well in this 30s 40s
aesthetic onward please don't do this
gas is coming for you
[Applause]
werewolf by night so as jovin screams a
cute mark appears in the upper right
corner now these marks are used to
signal projectionists that a film rail
is close to its end and it's about time
to switch reels for a 35 millimeter on a
two reeler that's about six reels total
for a two hour film the q mark is just
likely a stylistic thing like you'll
notice there's a lot of like glitching
in the editing in this trailer but it
could be another way that this ties in
the tva maybe all of this is playing on
the tva's film projector jack gets
grabbed by this giant hand through the
hedges and we later see that someone is
getting attacked by man thing man thing
confirmed to the mcu it's awesome so man
thing is dr ted salas who in the comics
works on a team to try to recreate the
super soldier serum in the florida
everglades but he gets pursued by aim
and during the escape he injects himself
with the serum and crashes his car in
the swamp where mystical forces cause
him to transform into manding a plant
matter humanoid who senses emotion and
gets enraged by fear and those who feel
fear who touch him get burned by a fluid
that he secretes that could be what's
happening here actually the magic that
transformed man think came from a rift
that's deep in that swamp to the nexus
of all realities yes my friends an
interdimensional rift to another realm
in the multiverse that ripped could have
been what led us to this black and white
horror pocket reality actually i love it
between the tva and the nexus of all
realities this whole werewolf by night
story just looks like it's taking place
in another pocket reality of the
multiverse of the mcu one where
supernatural paranormal horror creatures
live and all this intercourse with a
violent strobe lit room where jack in
his werewolf form slaughters the tva
agents even getting their blood on the
camera what i'm interested in is this
room's walls depict some illustrations
of beasts from folklore and these latin
phrases on the left side you see eleanor
puto which roughly translates to i
consider it alien which might be part of
a famous quote from the roman playwright
terence who said homo sum humane nil ami
elianum puto which means i am a human
being i consider nothing human alien to
me which is a phrase that you can
interpret in a couple different ways
really it means as a human every other
human i see is my brother in a way but
in this context it applies to things
like werewolves things that you see is a
monster but it's actually deep down a
human like you then over on the right
wall you can make out the words vocare
ad which means call to and then vivat
which means he lives we don't see all
the latin words yet so it's hard to get
the full context but it just sounds like
these phrases are referring to human
nature versus supernatural phenomena
that can overtake that human nature and
again this pocket reality could just be
where all supernatural mcu beans are
kept in the multiverse or i don't know
maybe it's a chapter in the dark hold
that now that the dark hole has been
destroyed has taken the form of a pocket
reality that is bleeding over into our
reality there were even rumors this week
that a blade cameo was planned for
werewolf by night but they couldn't line
up marshall ali's schedule but either
way this just gives you an idea of what
to expect all the nightmarish creatures
of the mcu could show up here including
mephisto or at least jake the goat get
the goat in there but onto the final
clip
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah elsa looks like she's being used as
bait in that cage as the werewolf closes
in on her to standing guard doing
nothing the real freeze is on her screen
and the celluloid burns on the projector
and this paints in the disney plus logo
and i just love the sound of the
flipping of a light switch and it turns
the color back on
this hour-long special is coming october
7th and i'm super excited for it thanks
for watching don't forget to check out
monster legends and start playing today
using the link in the description so
follow me on tik tok instagram and
twitter at eavos following rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you